[Music]
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about whatever we want
and of course we got your man right here
dumbfounded in the building
we also got anthony lee [ __ ] hosting
like a [ __ ] huh let's go
we also got random asians like nick and
bart and joe and he's asians too [ __ ] it
i'm a caucasian he's a caucasian hold
the asian
okay davidson says i'm basically an
asian so i'll take it thank you
they even gave you the asian card you
did after this many episodes on the
grounds i think so that means you're
allowed to say
you're allowed to [ __ ] now right
oh bro i'm gonna call everyone that if
they earn it
it's not a c card it's a ch card i mean
you gotta throw the ch together that's
right that's right my mistake by the
state no but david says that you know
i'm like you guys which is very very
nice
i don't think i'm as small as all of you
but
i will try to be i will try to be
huge bro
no bart's huge side to side i'm i'm up
and down
that's true he's got a girth factor not
a girth you got like a height factor
yeah [ __ ] it it's genetic [ __ ] not this
[ __ ] affectation [ __ ] yeah bart
does all kinds of trickery
i want to go work out at barbell brigade
oh you should stop by dude where is it
uh it's in uh right outside of chinatown
in l.a
oh [ __ ] i want to go
like like past chinatown and that little
you know where uh the brewery's at right
next to the brewery just go early
because parking is a [ __ ] if you don't
go early can i stop by my with my
trainer and check it out yeah okay cool
cool check it out and not fart who's
your number one competition in l.a i
don't think we have one
wrong food if they opened up a gym
food's gym real quick [ __ ] wong fu huh
i love those girls
for years these guys have been beefing
for years now i'm kidding listen we've
been battling i mean it
i don't like those guys yeah wall foo
would be your guys's uh you guys we have
junebes they have boba mofo
is that your
don't
guys
like you guys aren't the jabberwockies
[Laughter]
[ __ ] dogs no i think we're the
jabberwockies are kenjus
don't start yeah wow we're we're the
jabberwock so you're insisting that the
jabberwockies are better much yeah
that's what you're saying all day baby
let's go job walkies are trash
who's your number one rival whether it's
an actual rival with animosity or not
they don't you know when you like
[ __ ] just create rivals
i don't have a direct rival but i have
people i don't like it could be
respectful there's a lot of people i
don't like dude yeah yeah [ __ ] rivals
who do you [ __ ] hate dude
everyone got everyone has a petty list
right oh i say petty mom dude we all
petty walk out here i like that little
petty list you know i don't i mean i
would say it's not pettiness anymore
like i try to let go of that but you
never forget about people that you know
things they said what do you do do you
try to get people to hurt them no no no
no i just doesn't remember it like as
like you know it's like your fuel it's a
little bit of a fuel yeah but
it's just little i i just remember like
one-liner things that people say and
that's my petty more than them as a
person it's just like that thing they
said like in a battle rap you can't not
even battle rap battles is like that's
what you're supposed to do you know what
i mean i'm never offended by people i
battle because you're supposed to come
and say offensive [ __ ] i just wanted you
to be a sensitive battle rapper so then
you get your feelings hurt and they
would have been funny but
what is a line that you don't see the
person but the line that you're like oh
that [ __ ] kind of stung a little bit can
i step in
wait why are you
i don't understand why you should step
in right there
is my friend he said um we could have
made it we could have been millionaires
he said that to a group of my fantasy
football friends
and i'm like well i'm already gonna do
that so i'm gonna [ __ ] you up the ass
actually was it about crypto yeah so
he's saying that like he he passed her
past you or something like nine months
ago he said that like we did something
that [ __ ] up everything like we're
done
but i'm like oh no but i'm gonna do it
anyway and you're [ __ ] why would he
say that it's not even over yet i know
but he's a dumb [ __ ] but he would say
that to you as a group of people no he
was saying it to me in front of everyone
in my group so then i'm like bro don't
do this in front of my fanny phone did
he lose as much as i did no then i'd
slap him across the [ __ ] face he
didn't even know what i hate about that
thing is they make it seem like it's too
late for you to do that or something you
know what i mean like it's like your
journey's still going you know what i
mean did that be like you could have
like [ __ ] i'm doing it you know
what i mean like what are you doing i'm
saying they have no clue
i'm already at a level where he would
cry if he knew but i won't tell him yet
he's like that meme
only if they knew my coinbase account
like you know that little you know
and the leo dicaprio uh from the quentin
movie
inception i'm toby o'brien
no where he's like
yeah yeah yeah yeah
i i root for you guys like you man
because i am that guy too back to before
the random interruption though
so what is you don't have to drop names
like barcelona but what's something
what's your favorite haunted house
i think what triggers me is like you
know honestly sometimes like collabs
right like you approach somebody about a
collab of some sort it could be music it
could be a project you're working on and
they really brush you off like
you're not worthy of that collab and
then you get better than them and so
first of all i ask these people because
i feel like
we're worthy of each other's yeah yeah
featuring you know what i'm saying so
when they brush that off
it feels like i mean i'm going to feel a
certain way now i need to know names now
yeah before who though i don't want to
do that because i've gone i've gone in
my moments where i'm going off the names
and i've definitely gotten some trouble
not to go ham what if
it wasn't about you and what if they
were going through a divorce or
something sad and they just couldn't do
music and that's why you know and i've
talked about this with like i had a
podcast episode with bobby lee and bobby
hundreds we go through this like we go
through these invisible wars where in
our head there's like this war going on
but they don't know nothing about it so
a lot of times that's what pettiness is
right like you feel a certain way but
they don't even realize that you feel
this way [ __ ] that's i guess that's why
i'm petty officer is that is that a part
of k rage
how well do you know bobby though
bobby hundreds are bobby he's talking
about the double bobbies i know both of
them pretty well but because i worked
with bobby before i think any of you
even knew him and
uh he's the same guy but i have to say
it's it's so interesting because we used
to work on the show called equals three
with ray william johnson but the point
is that like yeah you you um you have to
just try to be a person but also at the
same time you have to try to not like uh
offend whatever his sensibility is and
all [ __ ] no i'm just saying i think
we're i think we're all i don't even
know why you need to bring
you know bobby too no bobby thought that
too no no actually no i have to say this
i have a suit bobby's talked about a lot
of like his pettiness and stuff you know
he talks about all the time like he's
had a beef with this
a comedian that i know of i'm friends
with too and they hate each other they
talk publicly about each other all the
time oh is it this is the [ __ ] uh the
asian guy kevin shay oh no kevin shay
he's another comedian aren't they the
king kim's of course yeah they were yeah
but they haven't and they've talked
publicly about like not liking each
other for over a decade but i just feel
like also you it's hard you shouldn't i
thought it was that fan but i feel like
you shouldn't i thought he hated that
one i feel like you shouldn't carry on
these beasts for that long because at
that point people started forgetting why
they hate each other too you just
remember the emotion yeah exactly not
even the reason at some point you should
let things go yeah you know this is how
i feel like
um if you hate someone that much kill
them
or let it go
or i don't really condone it
i don't know i have diamond hands with
my grudges
i i don't i don't sorry i don't i don't
mean you should kill people that's wrong
right i'm saying like oh okay what's the
point you mean like confront them yeah
you could do that you could squash it
you could do a lot of things but for me
that level of hate
should be met with that level of action
so keep the same energies so i'm like if
you if don't half-ass it right like if
if it's not really worth your pain then
let it go
if it's really worth that pain
because you feel that type of hate right
then act
don't recommend doing this but people
might you know you know what it is it's
like the reason people don't confront it
is because they want to kill them softly
like they want to kill them through
all this other [ __ ] success or whatever
because it feels more satisfying i guess
to them that they're
i don't know that's what i'm saying
that's what i think then you don't want
to commit murder but yes or you're
trying to like rebuttal that specific
line like for steve i don't think he
would uh make him feel satisfied if he
killed that guy yeah but if he did
exactly of that line which is we should
have been millionaires and he killed
them directly in that line then i think
it'd be satisfying
sometimes killing isn't even satisfying
at all no it's not yeah that's not by
the way petty [ __ ] though like [ __ ]
fuels me me too especially especially as
an adult i feel like when you know and
you're mature enough to control your
emotions and the way that your actions
will come off from things that you
experience and you know that it's going
to
breed some sort of like positive
reaction for your own self-being so
would you say you love pediatrics would
you say it's a good thing like isn't it
yeah [ __ ] yeah
for people who deserve it
who are you
listening absolutely no i'm curious
because everything that i was taught
about this topic makes it sound like
it's a toxic thing to have but who
taught you a barista yeah
i read a couple tweets
today's video is brought to you by
curology
so i've been getting curology packets or
packages to my home
and i finally have been using them
because i live in dry ass vegas
i never really needed it out here
because it's you know it's humid but in
vegas it got hella dry and i'm like oh
cool thank god i went on the website and
i click what i want i just have a
moisturizer and it's the basic cleanser
so i can clean my face from all the
training that i do and then moisturize
my skin and now my skin feels nice and
tight and young and i really like it and
i trust them because it's not like just
going into a store and you pick random
things off the shelf there's a license
provider that makes a custom formula
just for you i like the one that
helps me with dry skin because i have a
dry dry skin but all the oily and weird
parts and also i have sensitive skin and
i uh because i have like eczema and
stuff like that and i don't want to age
so it's like a like a cream that helps
keep my skin tight and beautiful what's
your formula so the one that i choose is
just a moisturizer that helps with acne
just so i could be camera ready all the
time especially since i do videos here i
do videos for barbell and i vlog and
sometimes i do close-ups so i just want
my skin as smooth and not as bumpy as
possible
i hope that one day they'll come out
with a dolphin option so you could be
dolphin-skinned yeah dolphins got the
best skin in nature you just pour water
on your face and it falls off mm-hmm
that's pretty cool maybe they will have
a dolphin option we just gotta make sure
that the license providers also know how
to do that but if you guys are want the
second best option to dolphin skin make
sure you check it out go to curology.com
off the record to get your first 30 day
trial for free all you have to do is pay
shipping and handling which is only five
bucks that's 30 days for free
curology.com off the record
these cats have taught me well not
really but i already knew it already i
had i had the pettiness of my heart but
it became more fun when i got to know
these cats and i'm like oh man we all
believe in the same thing
where we just want to say [ __ ] you to
the world which is really fun
if you could do that and you only got
two options right you either [ __ ]
drown in your own insecurity of whatever
is that they're saying or you prove them
wrong
but here's the thing people are saying
that's toxic because you should not have
to do it to prove to anybody anything it
should be for yourself but we've been
doing this asians been doing that since
day one
yeah what the [ __ ] they know no [ __ ]
they don't know no [ __ ]
or [ __ ] i know a couple dawg i don't
care i'm not yeah i'm not saying i'm not
guilty of it i do i do the same thing
but you're trying to let go of it i'm
just trying to figure that out or maybe
a different source of motivation i think
on some normal
regular day living life experience [ __ ]
absolutely i think there's idealisms
that need to be like for all humanity
and society just you know be the better
person but i think in like
a
healthy competition for people that are
trying to issue for people that have
ambition i think petty [ __ ] is [ __ ]
phenomenal fuel right i think there's a
difference between
seeking validation through your from
your enemies because you're obsessed of
what they said right that's a difference
from oh
that's what you think [ __ ] watch
i'm going to come back and my game is
going to be better
but i mean there it's one is competition
you made fun of my jump shot now i'm
going to come back and crush it
versus i'm thinking about you every
single day to crush you you are my and
then they have nothing to live for after
they prove them wrong yeah that's a sad
yeah because you're living for the
enemy's validation but the fine line
depending on on your level of greatness
i'm not for the sake of conversation i
think about like uh remember what
michael jordan said in uh [ __ ] the
last dance yeah how he like almost
fabricates a fabricates competition in
his own mind it's like somebody might
like kind of say something to him and
then in his mind he'll just eat
and i took that personally yeah every
tension is greatness and that's true we
do create it on our own you know like i
interpreted these one-liners that i
remember that pissed me off but i
interpreted it in the worst way possible
yeah cause they might not even have
mentality you're great
like okay i'll give you an example of a
real line that i heard a name too give
us a name one guy i asked i asked to
like do something you know form like
with me or for me because i did
something for him before timothy got
okay
[Laughter]
[ __ ] you tim i see [ __ ] no so i i i
asked him to do this thing and he said
he's like
this though i think the phrasing of it
really [ __ ] it up because he was like
uh no can do
he started with no can do right what did
you say
who talks like what's wrong with you
what did you do
would do anything does that sound a
little hilarious doesn't it sound like
some [ __ ] that could kind of piss you
off a little bit yeah
that's what i'm saying
so he said he said he couldn't because
of a thing but he started with like uh
no can do like i got a press thing or
whatever but it's just the way that it
sounded bro it sounds like you low balls
that does not sound like a pompous thing
like this supposed to be somebody like
we're supposed to be like we know each
other or whatever you disagree sorry no
i'm gonna start using that no i don't
know so that that right there pissed me
off and maybe it wasn't how he intended
it but to me that [ __ ] made me furious
bro
furious what do you got lord from the
eighteen hundreds or whatever oh no can
do like
i have to run it by my friends the walk
mom
do you guys think that's crazy
no yeah [ __ ] tim that's what we got
the vlog it's a phrasing of things so
i'm saying that was an example yeah
other thing that is that's the invisible
one i think
what pisses me off about pettiness about
tim is that the power
that person has over my mind yeah yeah
it makes so like there's a healthy level
of like for example you could get petty
over a roast and you're like that was
[ __ ] good you hit me for a second
i'mma get you but it's it it doesn't
consume your life if you're waking up in
the middle of the [ __ ] night because
you want to destroy this [ __ ] face that
becomes a unhealthy obsession that's why
i have to get out of battle rap bro
because i mean battle rappers like you
you prepare for a person for like a
month in advance
you're thinking about him every day bro
like a fight almost that's crazy yeah i
mean the same thing with a fight yeah
like 24 7 yeah that's crazy do fighters
think about like the opponent the whole
time as they're training they watch the
tape on the other person for like six
months right well athletes too right
again right on your chest it doesn't say
a wrap right now because i just see
reader say battle rap on my chest it
doesn't say a wrap add a wrap what do
you mean battle rap would be you know if
i saw your whole chest but obviously
i was just see a part of it
my karate teacher when he was competing
and he was he was fighting he would go
up to his opponents and be like why did
you rape my sister what the [ __ ] and
then the guy's like
what so he's creating so that [ __ ]
you're talking about michael jordan
that's a little bit like i don't know it
seems a little bit extra well i mean i
gotta hand it to them only crazy people
accomplish crazy things facts i'm sure
there's probably like 90 percent of them
that [ __ ] do terrible things but i'm
just saying like only crazy people you
have to go to a different place
crazy person just doing something but
that's a thing do we believe i mean okay
i think
nowadays
there's this huge movement to let people
know that you can be
healthy
mentally right and still do incredible
things i think the best way is is
thinking about using the force or the
dark force like the good or the bad
energy
because i see pettiness as dark force
energy and winning with that
because some people are motivated by uh
dark side is easier that is a good that
is a good description though like that
jedi and sith vibes you know what i mean
and then some people you can you know
using that pure energy i would say i
want to get more on the the
the pure energy yeah because i think i
thrived off of the dark energy for a
long time because a lot of artists do
yeah right we get into a dark place when
we're creating fire [ __ ] off of a crazy
breakup and you're sad you're depressed
or even your mentor telling you they
don't think you can make it like [ __ ]
you or like i have the high ground hey
to be honest some of the most incredible
art in the world comes from the darkest
places that's true though my bars have
gotten weaker since i started bouldering
every level i climb harder my bars get
weird until now you grab me bro
on top of that boater like my bars are
weak i feel like being too content
you let a lot of [ __ ] go and you don't
create i made it to sacrifice i think
once you get better in what one area you
you have to sacrifice some other areas
like even working out like that's that's
dedication and a lot of times an
artist's lifestyle doesn't fit in
working out because you might be in the
studio all night or whatever you're not
motivated to go the next morning so it's
a sacrifice your music might get better
but you might get unhealthy we know you
didn't get up because bart says like he
you that was [ __ ] 10 years ago i'm up
now [ __ ]
that was 10 [ __ ] yeah i know i'm on
this patty i remember i remember i'll
come to sessions like i'll be like
hungover and [ __ ] you know so like
that's not me anymore okay that's cool
yeah let's see your biceps against each
other yeah i'm sure
i'm sure you're really worked up worked
up for it yeah
hey man you might got some bouldering
forearms though you know i i think
health is not important man because even
me with my computer arms i promise i
crush this [ __ ] fool i'm saying look
at this [ __ ] [ __ ] you know what i
think look it's called crypto arms but
it's like it makes me sad like when you
look at the state of a lot of artists
right now in the current state and like
kids are dying like super early in
hip-hop and all this [ __ ] yeah like off
of health [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
like it's pretty sad that's my theory of
using that dark energy you end up
hurting your your collateral damage the
health everything you might become
successful and then you die
that's my [ __ ] too about white kids
where they're like hey look we have too
much healthcare like maybe we're gonna
get tested for too many things and i'm
like oh don't die
who can relate i don't even know what
that means real life who can relate
[Music]
you